one of those good people is joshua yoder
he's a commercial airline pilot he's
co-founder of the group us freedom
flyers he joins us tonight mr thanks so
much for coming on
so
summarize for us you you pilots who have
raised questions about these mandates
have been as noted
dismissed as criminals terrorists
tell us your motive in resisting this
mandate
tucker thanks for having me on of course
um
yes uh my motive for resisting it is is
primarily religious for myself uh
basically i saw
among my friends i saw a need
many of us don't want to take this so
people were being chorused i believe in
freedom and i'm here to support the
freedom of my fellow employees and all
people across this country
i'm not going to take a mandate i'm not
going to be coerced into doing something
that i don't believe in
so there are two levels in which to
assess this one is the the level that
you just described
the level that preserves american
society as we've known it for 250 years
with freedom at its core because if they
can make
airline pilots do this they can make
airline travelers do this and they can
there's no end to what they can make you
do but describe if you would since you
work in the business what the effect on
our national transportation
infrastructure is about to be because of
these mandates
well as we know the transportation
sector is the heart and soul of this
country and it's a very delicate system
if there's a disruption in one part of
the system it has a catastrophic effect
among the rest of the system which is
going to affect commerce it's going to
affect trade and ultimately it's going
to affect the economy if you have
flights reduced by 30 percent because 30
of pilots are fired because they won't
take the vaccine this is going to affect
how your goods get here from overseas
how they're distributed to the stores
you know the same thing is happening
with the truckers it's happening in the
shipping industry
those amazon boxes that typically show
up in two days you might be looking at
three weeks
so i mean it turns out that people with
essential skills like airline mechanics
air traffic controllers and yes
commercial airline pilots have more
power
maybe than they realized you've got to
wonder if people are being pushed to the
point where they're going to be fired
how many more of these
sick outs
job actions whatever strikes whatever
you're going to call what we saw this
weekend how many more of these do you
think we're likely to see
well first of all we have all the
control and the control comes from a
simple word and that's no we just don't
need to comply
as far as i'm concerned i will never
promote a sick out or a work action that
is illegal uh with u.s freedom flyers
the organization that i'm with we will
never promote such a thing with that
being said we also cannot control the
actions of individuals
and i think that i think that you will
see massive disruptions in supply chain
and in your travel if we just stand up
and say no if these companies fire us
and they fire 30 percent of the
workforce aircraft are going to stop
moving and it's going to affect you it's
going to affect your air travel and it's
going to affect the economy
joe biden will say this is your fault
finally how do you respond to that he'll
blame you for this
it's his fault it's squarely his fault i
think anyone with a with a critical mind
can point towards the federal government
and the companies that are enforcing
these illegal mandates from the federal
government and and see that it's the
federal government's fault it certainly
is it certainly is this is an amazing
moment joshua yoder thank you so much
for coming on tonight for your bravery
appreciate it
thank you